mr. president great to see you thank you
very much you literally just finished
the press conference with President
Putin moments ago a lot came up you were
very strong at the end of that press
conference he said where are the servers
what about what Peter's truck said where
are the 33,000 emails and there was this
mystery answer that I think surprised a
lot of people by the President of Russia
as it relates to the molar investigation
well first of all he said there was no
collusion whatsoever
I guess he said as strongly as you can
say it they have no information on Trump
it was an interesting statement too you
know many years ago when I was there
what was it 13 for a long time ago he
said there were many many business
people there in all fairness I was a
very successful businessman but I was
one of a lot of people and one thing you
know if they had it they would have been
out and so he said it's nonsense is
right and he also said there's
absolutely no collusion which you know
and everybody that watches your show
knows and I think most of the country
knows and Tucker standing right over
there definitely knows because he gets
it he's one of the people to get it but
I'll tell you that I thought it was a
really amazing time not about that I
think it's a shame we're talking about
nuclear proliferation we're talking
about Syria and humanitarian aid we're
talking about all of these different
things and we get questions on the witch
hunt and I don't think the people out in
the in the country buy it but the
reporters like to give it a shot I
thought that President Putin was very
very strong let's talk about how the day
went you actually used the term four
hours ago that changed talking about the
relationship was it that quickly and
that were found at a very long meeting
and it was a good meeting we discussed
so many different things including
nuclear including war and peace
including economic Syria Ukraine we
discussed many many things
at the end of a long period of time I
mean it was really a lot I was just the
two of us and interpreters and at the
end of this meeting I think we really
came to a lot of good conclusions a
really good conclusion for Israel
something very strong he's a he's a
believer in Israel he's a fan of Bibi
and really helping him a lot and we'll
help him a lot which is good for all of
us let's talk about specifics that you
went over as it relates to both Syria
which he has been a supporter of the
Assad regime and of course Iran which is
the number one state sponsor of terror
fomenting proxy wars well I think that
Syria we're getting very close I think
it's becoming a humanitarian situation
and a lot of people are going to move
back to Syria from Turkey and from
Jordan and from different places they're
going to move back less so from Europe
but they will be moving back from lots
of different places so I really think
we're not very far apart on Syria I do
think that on Iran he probably would
have liked to keep the deal in place
because that's good for Russia you know
they do business with it's good for a
lot of the countries that do business
with Iran but it's not good for this
country and it's ultimately not good for
the world and if you look at what's
happening Iran is falling apart they
have riots in all their cities the
inflation is rampant in going through
the roof and not that you want to hurt
anybody but that regime we would let the
people know that we are behind them a
hundred percent but they're having big
protests all over the country probably
as big as they've ever had before and
that all happens since I terminated that
deal so we'll see you know they were
talking about a new partner with Russia
to perhaps stop the fomenting a terror
of stop the proxy wars was that
discussed well it was and I think that
would be a great thing if we could do it
then you have some people that say oh
you'd have to do you know get involved
with Russia but if we can stop killing
all over the place or terrorism we
discussed radical Islamic terror at
great length because they have the
problem - yeah we discussed Isis as you
know we've pretty much eradicated Isis
in the Middle East and we've done
various
he acknowledged that but we discussed
Isis and the threat of Isis and
basically the threat of terrorism let me
go to the issue of nuclear proliferation
2021 the START treaty would need to be
extended and also the INF as it relates
to and he did bring up the idea of
missile defense were those issues
discussed and did you make any progress
well I think we're at the very beginning
that's a very important issues to me the
most important issue is the nuclear
issue because I know President Obama
said global warming is our biggest
problem and I would say that no its
nuclear warming is our biggest problem
by a factor of about five million the
nuclear problem we have to make sure we
have to be very careful and you know if
you look at Russia and the United States
that's 90 percent of the nuclear weapons
we're doing something and working on
other countries and he also said he
wants to be very helpful with North
Korea we're doing well with North Korea
we have time
there's no rush you know it's been going
on for many years but we're doing very
well as you know we got our hostages
back there's been no testing there's
been no nuclear explosions which we
would know it about immediately there's
been no Rockets going over Japan no
missiles going over Japan and that's now
been nine months and the relationship is
very good you saw the nice letter he
wrote and so I think a lot of good
things are happening but President Putin
is very much into making that all happen
a lot of people in the lead-up to this
obviously you've met with our NATO
allies and America pays seventy cents of
every dollar and a lot of people have
not lived up to their commitment as it
relates to that and also interestingly
because a big part of NATO's mission is
to prevent any hostility from Russia and
yet Angela Merkel's willing to put
import billions of dollars worth of
their energy up to 70 percent which I
would argue would make them vulnerable
and
Russia billions of dollars now that's
her choice I mean she's going to do it
but it's a little tough when you're in
NATO and you do that I will say that I
was amazed at the media because honestly
I was there for a day and a half and it
started right when I got there and I was
very respectful but I told people that's
unfair the United States could be paying
for ninety one percent okay could be so
the minimum is 70 percent but it's
probably ninety one so we're paying for
ninety one percent of the cost of
keeping Europe safe on top of that the
European Union takes total advantage of
us with tariffs and with trade barriers
that they kill us on trade we lost a
hundred and fifty 1 billion dollars last
year so they beat us on trade and we
defend them for essentially nothing and
I said not going to be that way anymore
you got to pay up you had to say
military general gave you the credit he
gave me all of the credit last last year
there is forty four billion dollars more
only because more additional and he said
it was only because of president drop so
I figured I'd wake up the next day and
read these wonderful stories and and by
the way I can't even really look at you
through that I actually thought finally
I'm gonna have a great story
ok foreign relations I'm gonna have a
great story and instead of saying that I
raised 44 billion not million forty four
billion last year for NATO
I raised could be over a hundred billion
dollars this year and into the future
they said that I treated the heads of
other nations rough they and I didn't I
actually have great relationships with
them